hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the basic
ideas that central to manual kant's duty
based or deontological ethics is what we
call the categorical imperative and I
have another video in which I talk about
the other types of imperatives I'm not
going to distinguish it here from
hypothetical imperatives we're just
going to focus on the categorical
imperative and actually we're only going
to focus on the first formulation of it
in this video and we're also just going
to talk about it in general terms I'm
shooting two other videos in which I'll
give you some specific examples that
we'll go over to see how it would apply
now a categorical imperative is sort of
at the root of Kant's moral theory tells
us what we ought to do it gives us a
clear understanding in his view of what
our duties are and what our duties to
not do certain things are as well so
there are certain things that are duties
that we want to be doing and like we was
sudden in previous videos we ought to be
doing them for the sake of Duty because
they're the right thing and if that's
the case then there's other things with
me ought not to be doing so for instance
if we have a duty to tell the truth we
have a duty not to lie or to lie another
way of putting it goes contra
or against doing flying is immoral
precisely because telling the truth is
morally required the categorical
imperative helps us figure out what in
fact our duties are and this is very
important because when we talk about
Duty based ethics a lot of people have
the the general view that well we just
have duties and they're out there and we
know what they are and people tell us
hey you have a duty to do this as a son
or daughter you have a duty to do this
as a student or professor you would duty
to do this as a citizen but the question
that's left on the answer is well why
precisely do I have those duties how do
I know that that's actually what I'm
supposed to do so the categorical
imperative is supposed to answer that
question now in consu
our duties that we have is individual
human beings as individual rational
beings our duties that everybody has so
they're not really role specific the way
they are and some other data logical
views they're not coming to us as well
from from a bog or from outside somebody
imposing the mahdis and saying you have
a duty to do this these are things that
we ought to be able to discover by the
application of our Faculty of reason and
that's what the categorical imperative
has us do so let's look now at this
first formulation reads like this and
only on that Maxim through which you can
at the same time will that it should be
a universal law so what does that mean
well there there are several parts to
that and I want to go through each of
those in turn
in part because students will often have
some some misunderstandings about these
or confusions you notice I've also put
on the board what is cannot saying
because there are certain certain wrong
directions that students will take this
I've seen it happen in papers on tests
and conversations in class certain ways
in which this gets misread that come up
over and over and over again so I want
to try to address
so that when you're watching this you
can get a solid understanding of what
Kahn is saying and what he's not saying
so let's start first with what he is
saying act only on that Maxim through
which you can at the same time will that
it should be a universal law so what is
this telling you this is telling you
that in general you should act only on
Maxim's you should only do things you
should only engage in actions you should
only intend to do things you should only
will to do things Maxim remembers a way
of describing what it is that you intend
to do or want to do or choosing to do or
are doing you should only act on Maxim's
that fit the rest of this criteria right
so that's saying that if you're going to
be a moral being you should only do
certain things and you shouldn't do
other things certainly shouldn't do
things that go against what this is
going to provide so we head through
which you can at the same time will that
it should become a universal law the
next really important conception here is
this idea of becoming a universal law
this is often called the
universalization or the
universalizability principle that that
if something is moral if you're going to
say that somebody should do it it's the
right thing to do everybody should do it
you're saying if if person a should do
it person B should do it and anybody
else who comes along who happens to be a
person ought to do it as well
so for instance if lying is the wrong
thing to do it's not just wrong for me
it's wrong for everybody if telling the
truth is the right thing to do as Kant
does believe it was the case then it's
the right thing not only for me to do
but for you to do and anybody else who
would come along well you know they
to do it as well that's what it means
for it to be a universal izybelle
comment is saying you have to imagine
you have to use your your capacities as
a human being to think about how or
whether this thing that you want to do
that you're wondering hmm is this is
this okay for me is this the right thing
to do is this the wrong thing to do
let's say we said everybody's going to
do that it's going to become a universal
law and not a law like you know the
policeman comes along and says oh oh you
know if you don't do this you're going
to go to court we're going to haul you
in rather a law of nature meaning that
everybody would do this so you have to
carry out kind of a thought experiment
if you want to say that everybody should
tell the truth now imagine everybody
telling the truth in every circumstance
and that that would become the way in
which human beings behave that would be
the kind of universe that you're going
to live in some things cut things if you
think about them they can't really work
out like that what do we mean by this
this is kind of hard to wrap your head
around how thinks that there's a logical
not necessarily impossibility on its
face but an impossibility or a
contradiction as you think it through as
you work it up so let's say we take
lying for example lying and telling the
truth right you say is it okay for me to
to lie well what would happen then if
everybody lied if the maximum is well
whatever it's convenient for me I'll
tell a lie then anybody whenever they're
in a situation where it's convenient to
them they shall tell a lie that would be
the universal
nation of that that maximum current
seems to think that if you try to
imagine a world like that sooner or
later you're going to like run into like
a mental brick wall because you're going
to realize you know if that was the case
then the whole idea of lying in truth
would it would break down and there
wouldn't be any difference between
between the two or they become
indistinguishable or their you know no
meaning to the to the act of lying let
alone to the truth so that means that
couldn't work there would be a
contradiction there some sort now there
are some things that can't thinks that
you could imagine to be universalized
certain max certain choices certain
actions the way that we could describe
them that you could imagine to apply
universally you could say well everybody
will act like that everybody can't act
like that but you wouldn't be able at
the same time to will that to be the
case so why couldn't you will that to be
the case here's a place where can't
admittedly starts to get a little bit
maybe maybe not entirely consistent see
here's the thing Conte says that
consequences don't matter Duty based
ethics is not based on the idea that
it's going to pay off if we all behave
this way the way you know so utilitarian
ethics does for you know other forms of
consequentialism contract Aryan ethics
those sorts of things instead he says
this is something that you
who can sort of figure out by using
reasonable but whether you could will
that or not would really depend whether
you could will your Maxim becoming
universal law if it can in fact become a
universal law
you can't imagine a world in which that
would be the case can you will that
world that really depends on whether it
makes sense for you to want yourself to
be in that kind of world and it's a
little bit difficult admittedly to see
why you would want or not want to be in
a certain kind of world depending on
what kind of world it was depending on
the effects that would be produced by
making that kind of a policy across the
board so to speak
cut doesn't think that this is really
falling into that in his view of what
we're doing is we're just engaging in in
practical reason without any sort of
empirical admixture of consequences or
effects or that sort of thing affecting
our our motives and again I realized
that this is a little bit hard to
swallow but here's the way that Kant
more or less sees it this is conceivable
but there are some things that you can't
will it because if you were to will that
your will would be in a certain way
inconsistent you would be willing things
that go against go against what is
either in your interest or what you want
to to be something that would involve
some sort of process of development when
we look at the examples you'll see that
that this is more or less the way he
talks about so I understand that this is
a little bit tricky but what I do want
to say here is look we've got three main
parts to this Act only on that Maxim so
this is specified we're looking at
general types of behavior that we can
describe
we're saying only those are going to be
moral which we can say would become a
universal law of nature so everybody
would be doing them and you can also
will them to be a universal law of
nature so there's no inconsistency in
you're willing there's no inconsistency
in the idea of that kind of behavior or
choice universalized itself so you're
looking for inconsistencies
inconsistencies in the kind of world
that you're imagining inconsistencies in
willing that kind of world for you as a
person now that's what Conte is is
actually saying let's talk now but what
he's not saying because again this is
where I see students get mixed up a lot
and you know when my students do this I
point this out to them but perhaps if
you're a student in somebody else's
class they might you know come down hard
on you and say you've totally
misunderstood Conte and not give you a
second chance or something with that so
Conte is not saying this is the first
mistake I see people making content
saying that everybody does follow these
laws as a matter of fact he knows that
most of the time people don't follow
these laws he tells you that in the
ground where he says you know we tend to
make exceptions for ourselves so he's
not asserting that if you if you want to
say that that telling the truth is duty
that you're actually asserting because
of this categorical imperative that
everybody tells the truth that would be
crazy kind of actually thanks no it's
it's totally the opposite it's because
of the fact that a lot of people don't
actually tell the truth in this world
that we actually have to really push
ourselves to tell the truth so he's not
saying that everybody does follow that
law he's also not saying that you
couldn't empirically that is in the kind
of being that you actually are you
couldn't have a conflicted will in a
certain sense and you know carrying this
out so
you know if you for instance had a hard
time keeping your hands off of other
people's stuff because you like to steal
other people's stuff you can still at
the same time will that it be a
universal law that everybody should
respect each other's property and you
that you will that to be the case you
just would like it also not to be the
case because you'd like to steal other
people's stuff and you realize that
that's a problem for you right you see
that the difference there in that case
you have a bifurcated will your
inclinations are drawing you one way but
reason is telling you hey this is
something that can be universalized you
know we ought not to steal from from
people I want to think that of a
universal world universal condition in
which nobody steals everybody respects
everybody else's property and I actually
will that you can have to you have a
will that's empirically sort of going in
two different directions and then you
choose to favor this direction as a
matter of fact Khan says that's when you
can tell that a person really is acting
out of duty when they have to go against
their inclinations now the third thing
comp doesn't say that this would
necessarily produce good effects that's
not where the impetus of consciente
ontological moral theory lies it's not
about producing good effects good
consequences I understand that when you
look at this it kind of looks like I'm
imagining a world and seeing how it
would turn out for myself the context
what you're really imagining what you're
really thinking about is whether there
is an inconsistency in in this in this
and in thinking about this or whether
there's an inconsistency in willing that
that same thing the last thing if you
can't universalize it is it immoral in
the case of some things
if you can't universalize it this would
make it in morale so if you're only
acting on Maxim's that you can actually
will to be universal off when it comes
to what we call strict duties then it's
telling you look you have to do this and
if you don't do this you're doing the
wrong thing you're acting immorally by
by not doing that you're acting morally
by doing the right thing
there are some things that are called
non strict duties meritorious duties and
they're not duties in quite the same
sense instead those duties they tell you
what you want to do but if you don't do
them you're not actually like
necessarily doing something immoral
you're just not acting morally so
there's a fundamental difference between
the two of those so that's where we
leave off with this